- Il y a d'abord eu l'Europe, ùu
l'
de volailles domestiques, puis
les États-Unis, l'Alberta,
l'Ontario et maintenant
le Québec : la grippe aviaire
est à nos pPHPHPHPHPHPHPHPHPHPHr
v.-prés. Éleveurs volailles, QC
- C'est sûr que c'est quelque
chose qui nous préoccugagagagag,
c'est notre vie nous autres :
les oiseaux, puis nourrir
le Canada et le Québec.
- Pour l'instant, l'Agencedededs
aliments ne parle que d'un seul
popopossible au Québec, en
attente de confirmation.
identifié trois cas de grippe
chez des oiseaux sauvages dans
le sud du Québec.
sérieuse : il n'existe pas de
trai p p p pour cette maladie à
mortalité élevée qui se répand
comme une trainée de poudre.IEI.
médecine vétérinaire, UdeM
- On a une souche H5N1 qui ne
cause pas de maladie chez l'être
humain, mais qui affeaeaeaeaeaet
très excrété par les oiseaux
malades. Ce qui fait que
l'environnement est très
contaminé.
- La meilleure protection pour
constante de l'équipement à
l'entrée et à la sortie d
bâtiments d'élevages.
- Le temps est très important.
Plus on peut réagir parce qu'on
a des plans d'intervention, plus
on peut le faire rapidement,
contenir le problème.
- Dans l'industrie québécoise de
la volaille, qui regroupe plus
de 700 producteurs, on s'affaire
depuis plusieurs semaines à
informer les membres et à
sécuriser les installations.
ont tous été avertis soit par
des liens zoom, avec le
qui a donné des conférences,
quasiment deux ou trois reprises
- Chez les petits produc
certifié bio, l'enjeu est
différent.
propriétaire, Ferme Bibeau
- Commnenenenene production
diversifiée avec plusieurs
productions différentes, on n'a
nos oeufs dans le même panier.
- Sa crainteêêêtre
obligé d'enfermer ses volailles
comme tous les producteurs
le faire.
- Imaginons que, par
pendant toute la saison
estivale, moi, je ne peux pas
Bien là, moi, je ne peux plus
maintenir ma certification
biologique par exemple pour
les animaux. Donc ça veut dire :
ma production de e e e e e e e ,
et durablement.
- Durant les dernières semaines,
plus de 250 000 oiseaux sontasas
au Canada.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.